kevin is with us in san diego hi kevin
how are you
good dave how are you better than i
deserve how can we help
so anyways uh i appreciate you guys for
taking my call
um a little back story i just recently
separated from the military
i did about 10 years currently i'm a
full-time
student utilizing the post-911 gi bill
i also just recently took a government
contracting position full-time
in san diego which pays about sixty
thousand dollars annually
good my wife is a uh registered nurse
but uh we just had a baby back in
january so she's a stay-at-home mom for
now
uh anyways um my question is regarding
uh
equity in our mortgage uh we owe about
300
000 uh and our house is currently worth
about 450.
um my wife and i are almost debt-free
we've paid off almost 60 thousand
dollars of debt
but my question is would it be smart to
take out about 20 or 30 000
in equity out of our mortgage to pay off
the rest of the debt
and possibly upgrade some things in the
home no
it wouldn't be that's not a wise move at
all
um again and you set the numbers don't
make sure you're hearing correctly
what's your household income right now
60 60 all together okay cool and you
said
you have about twenty thousand dollars
in debt
uh about yeah about that yeah yeah
yeah i'm i'm not touching the home loan
uh i'm not the home law i'm not touching
equity at all what i'm doing is i'm
trying to come up with a game plan and
knock out this 20 000
cash so kevin thank you for your service
um your wife is at home with a new baby
and she's standing around inside that
house looking and seeing everything that
needs to be fixed
and that's what started that's what
started this conversation
it did i came home to a list of things
like
i was afraid i read that right oh my
gosh
and so uh yeah the answer is no babe
when you are able to get back to work
we'll be able to do these this list of
things
after we've gotten out of debt and have
our emergency fund in place
yeah so you cannot borrow your way into
abundance
yeah i i understand
um i do receive a housing allowance
through the 911
the post-911 gi bill you get that
whether you do these repairs or not
yeah so instead of taking out would it
be smart just to use that
money uh now it'd be smart to use that
money to get out of debt like every
other piece of money you've got yeah
because you're in baby step two and
you're knocking the debt out you got a
brand new baby we're trying to get out
of debt
how much is your housing allowance kevin
um the housing allowance is about three
thousand dollars but you get that
no matter what you you can do with it
what you want to do with it
come on man so now we're at 78.
that's what i'm saying in household
income right
yeah now you're out of nowhere i'm sorry
36 did you say 3 000 3 000
a month right kevin yeah 3
000 uh of housing allowance oh i'm sorry
now we're at 96 000
household income now we're out of debt
in five months
yeah and then you save up and do the
repairs what's the uh what's the cost on
the repairs gonna be
um
rough numbers probably around ten
thousand dollars okay so here's the
thing
you have a ninety six thousand dollar
income you need thirty thousand dollars
you should be done with both of these
in one year without borrowing a dime
okay
okay so um now
what we've got to do is walk through hit
this what happens is
uh the p that very few people
uh look at
a situation like this and and and
they're
really doing a bunch of math and they're
really thinking about how it's going to
turn out 15 years from now they're more
thinking about the here and now
yes and that's what drives you to ask a
question like do i borrow money to fix
up a house
while i'm still in debt right and answer
to all of it of course is no
and the reason we answer the question we
did is what helps kevin and his
wife and new baby be in the best place
10 years from today not 10 days from
today not 10 months from today
10 years from today what is best for you
and your family
what is going to put you in the most
money situation
and that is to have avoided the debt and
paid cash
for the repairs and have paid off your
existing debts yes
and that's going to continue to free
money up and continue to give you
options
and continue to do these things and it's
just a normal thing for her to be
sitting at home
you know she's you know she's dealing
with a human that can't talk back to her
all day
and so um that is highly needy
and uh and so it's in human nature to
walk around and go well we need to paint
that we need to fix that and
they didn't even notice it before come
on now and that's just normal there's
nothing wrong she didn't do anything
wrong
but that's shorter term thinking and we
need to think what's best for this child
long term 10 years 20 years out yes sir
yes and if you put it through that
paradigm
that's how anthony's quick answer as
soon as you ask a question was
no no with no explanation
zero not a chance no